أجتاح الأجانب والفوضى المدن الإيرانية لأشهر
مذعورين الآباء يشاهدون بلا حول ولا قوة بينما
يقع أطفالهم فريسة لأمراض غامضة
تواصلت شبكة CNN مع الشهود
والناجين من بعض هذه الحوادث في
مدارس الفتيات في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
لقد كان وضعًا فظيعًا كانت الفتيات
تسقط على الأرض  وكانوا
يبكون ، وكان البعض غير قادرين على المشي حقًا
لم يرغبوا في ترك بعضهم البعض ،
ولم يسمحوا لنا بالعودة إلى المنزل ، وأجبرونا على
البقاء في الداخل ، وكانت هناك رائحة مريرة ،
وكانت هناك رائحة في الخارج أيضًا ، ثم
شعرت بالغثيان للعديد من الطلاب  الذين تحدثوا
إلى شبكة سي إن إن أفادوا بشم روائح كريهة
بسبب تغير تفسير السلطات الإيرانية ،
لكن وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
تشير الآن إلى الحوادث حيث أن حالات التسمم
يخشى بعض الآباء من أن تكون هذه
الهجمات تستهدف الفتيات بهدف منعهن
من الذهاب إلى المدرسة ، وقد وقعت العديد من
الهجمات في
قلب إيران الديني ، لكن وزير
التعليم قال إن معظم
الحالات كانت بسبب الشائعات ولا توجد
مشكلة في أن حالات التسمم المبلغ عنها بدأت بعد
شهر ونصف من اندلاع العملية في
جميع أنحاء إيران بقيادة نساء يتظاهرن
ضد السلوك القمعي للبلاد.
قوانين الملابس عبرت CNN عن
تقارير وسائل الإعلام المحلية مع شهادات
الضحايا وشهود العيان لإحصاء
عدد الحوادث التي أبلغت عنها وسائل الإعلام الحكومية عن
حوادث في ما يقرب من 60 مدرسة
منذ أواخر تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر).
من اللثة
تم الإبلاغ عن ثلاث حوادث على الأقل لشبكة CNN ، كان
آخرها هذا الأسبوع
استمرار الإبلاغ عن حدوث
هذا الأسبوع في بلدات أوصفهان ،
وحيث تخبرنا المصادر الطبية أن
طالبًا تم إدخاله إلى وحدة العناية المركزة
يعاني من نوبات صرع بعد
الحادث الأخير وهو واحد من العشرات.  الذين تم
نقلهم إلى المستشفى لعائلة أخرى ينضمون إلى
المئات اليائسين للحصول على إجابات لندن